although a hefty dose of controversy can
cause some movies to bomb at the box
office
plenty of others have made some serious
Bank despite ticking a load of people
off and some made it big because they
annoyed people so what are these movies
how much should they make and just how
did they cause so much controversy here
are the most successful controversial
movies of all time
some hangsen Ron Howard made us be the
two nicest guys in Hollywood but the two
still somehow court said serious
controversy when they became attached to
the screen adaptation of one of the most
contentious and successful novels of
modern times the DaVinci Code
while the scholarship behind The Da
Vinci Code has largely been dismissed by
experts essential claims that Jesus
Christ were secretly married to Mary
Magdalene helped make the movie an
international bestseller the controversy
surrounding the 2006 movie was largely
the same for the 2003 novel with people
claiming it was both historically
inaccurate and anti-catholic critics
panned it when it was released - giving
it a measly 25 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes and moviegoers weren't too
impressed either giving it a mediocre 57
percent audience score nevertheless the
film's popular source material was
enough to score a 77 million dollar
opening weekend and by the time it was
out of theaters it had earned at 217
million dollar domestic haul as well as
an astounding 758 million dollar
worldwide gross Studios didn't see any
financial upside in Mel Gibson's graphic
retelling of Jesus Christ final hours
especially considering the actor turned
director wanted to film in the dead
languages of Aramaic and Latin and since
Gibson couldn't find financing for his
passion project
he paid nearly 30 million dollars on it
straight out of his own wallet but that
was just the start of the firestorm
leading up to the Passion of the Christ
2004 Ash Wednesday release day the film
became a lightning rod for controversy
centered around destroy violence and
alleged anti-semitism regarding the
former Roger Ebert said this is the most
violent film I have ever seen meanwhile
the anti-defamation league highlighted
what they perceived as the movies
anti-semitic views saying the
ramifications of this film will reach
far beyond Hollywood with the
possibility that it will feel new and
semitism but for this movie Gibson
circumvented the traditional movie
publicity routes instead targeting
evangelical Christians and his gamble
paid off The Passion of the Christ had
an 83 million dollar opening weekend
eventually earning three hundred and
seventy million dollars domestically and
six hundred and eleven million dollars
worldwide paramount Noah was one of the
most high-profile religious releases in
recent years a 2014 film stars Russell
Crowe as a titular Ark builder in an
adaptation of the story from the book of
Genesis so what's the controversy here
well the film mostly used the biblical
interpretation controversy stood over
several elements such as the film's
environmentalists themes that biblical
Nephilim being portrayed as giant rock
monsters and perhaps most notably the
whole in the beginning creation story
being equated with evolution the cool on
the creators part
[Music]
and they create a made man my aside one
oh and director Darren Aronofsky is also
an outspoken atheist and even bragged
that his film was the least biblical
biblical movie ever made so yeah you can
see how that might have ruffled a few
feathers
especially with Paramount's who were
purposefully trying to appeal to
Christian audiences but Aronofsky's
creative license wasn't enough to sink
Noah with critics or the box office the
film garnered a 76% rating on Rotten
Tomatoes
it turns 101 million dollar stateside
and three hundred and sixty-two million
dollars worldwide on a one hundred and
twenty five million dollar budget
released in 2013 the wolf of wallstreet
was a fifth collaboration between
director Martin Scorsese and star
Leonardo DiCaprio and it's basically 180
minutes of pure unadulterated debauchery
after all for a movie to be considered
controversial because of its content
alone in this day and age well you know
has to be incensed and this movie really
does have it all hard drug use check
explicit content check extreme profanity
double check in fact the wolf of Wall
Street holds a Guinness world record for
the most expletives used in a film the F
bomb is dropped 506 times for an average
of two point 81 times per minute but the
controversy didn't just come from what
was shown on screen
the film's producers also paid the US
government sixty million dollars after
allegations that the movie was funded
with money stolen from a Malaysian state
investment fund
Jordan Belfort whose own criminal
activities are vividly depicted in the
film even colder produces criminals if
the producers are upset about paying
sixty million dollars however they were
no doubt relief when the film made 160
million dollars domestically and three
hundred and ninety two million dollars
worldwide Basic Instinct may have been
the ninth biggest domestic box-office
hit of 1992 but it was easily the most
controversial the film comes from two of
Hollywood's most notorious provocateurs
director Paul Verhoeven
and screenwriter Joe Eszterhas the Basic
Instinct Eszterhas was paid three
million dollars making it one of the
most expensive original screenplays ever
sold
despite esterhaz this multi-million
dollar payday critics weren't impress
for the final film but both Sharon
Stone's performance and the film itself
are remembered for one controversial
scene in particular the one in which
stone and crosses her legs it's hard to
imagine an a-list actress doing a scene
like that today and it was pretty much
an thermoball in 1992 but it paid off
Basic Instinct made 170 million dollars
domestic and three hundred and fifty two
million dollars worldwide on a forty
nine million dollar budget Joe Eszterhas
earned his historic paycheck and Sharon
Stone proved risque content as a
bankable commodity worldwide
despite some fairly crazy sequel ideas
the Ghostbusters franchise remained
firmly in developmental hell for nearly
thirty years after ghostbusters 2 and
the first Ghostbusters film in almost
three decades wasn't exactly a sequel
that reunited Bill Murray dan Aykroyd
and the gang as many had hoped instead
it was a reboot starring an all-female
squad featuring Melissa McCarthy a
Kristen Wiig Kate McKinnon and Leslie
Jones the film sparked controversy after
just the first trailer with criticism
centering around Leslie Jones the lone
african-american on the team playing a
blue-collar worker and not a scientist
like the others screw that
we are scientists that's petty the
controversy didn't end there though
Ghostbusters was attacked by hordes of
Internet fans before they had even seen
the film with many cultural critics
suggesting the knee-jerk vitriol was a
result of sexism the film's director
Paul Feig even went so far as to say
geek culture is home to some of the
biggest I've ever met in my life
while most critics seem to like it
giving it a 74% Rotten Tomatoes ranking
the audience score was a rotten 50
percent however that low score didn't
really match up with the box office
numbers the film opened at number one
with 46 million dollars on his way to a
one hundred and twenty eight million
dollar domestic and two hundred and
twenty nine million dollar worldwide
tally alas the film cost one hundred and
forty-four million dollars to produce
so while Ghostbusters made a lot of
money as far as controversial movies go
it bummed as a summer blockbuster
angels and demons it's a 2009 sequel to
Ron Howard's 2006 blockbuster The Da
Vinci Code
once again Tom Hanks plays Harvard
symbologist Robert Langdon
this time the professor must work with
the nuclear physicists to solve a
killing and prevent a terrorist attack
against the Vatican based on Dan Brown's
controversial novel of the same name the
Vatican believed angels and demons was
anti-catholic and ban the production
from filming in the Holy See the Vatican
even contemplated calling for a boycott
Tom Hanks didn't see what all the fuss
was about however saying everyone is
looking for some scandal whether a
scandal exists or not I think a kind of
natural reaction is now that somehow
because it's a second Robert Langdon
mystery that there is some degree of
controversy over it and there is really
nuts however one feels about the
controversy behind the movie it clearly
wasn't just a few Catholics who didn't
like it
critics pander to giving it a rotten 37
percent tomato meter score still angels
and demons made a whole heap of dough
133 million dollar stateside and four
hundred and eighty-five million dollars
worldwide on a one hundred and fifty
million dollar budget James Cameron is
easily one of the most bankable
directors of all time having directed
the highest-grossing film ever Twice
first was 1997 Titanic which was sunk by
Cameron's own avatar in 2009 and while
Cameron is able to make it rain he's
also good at stirring the pots
case in point True Lies released in 1994
True Lies as a remake of the French
action comedy lot total and stars Arnold
Schwarzenegger as a CIA agent who
pretends to be a boring mild-mannered
computer salesman to his wife Jamie Lee
Curtis bataknese bizarre casting as a
nerd wasn't a made true lies so
controversial a loose coalition of Arab
Americans called for a boycott of the
film due to its depiction of the movies
Arab terrorists villains the film was
likewise decried a sexist because of
Jamie Lee Curtis is infamous striptease
scene controversy followed the film
years after its release when Eliza
Dushku who played Schwarzenegger and
Curtis as daughter alleged she was
assaulted by the film stunt coordinator
despite the controversy past and present
True Lies made 146 million dollars to
mystically and 378 million dollars
worldwide on a one hundred and fifteen
million dollar budget Quentin Tarantino
and controversy go together like well
Quentin Tarantino and swearing
wasn't your run-of-the-mill foul
language that sparked controversy in the
wake of the directors 2012 film Django
Unchained no this time it was the n-word
which was drops more than 100 times
during the film's nearly three hour
runtime Leonardo DiCaprio who played
cruel racist slave owner Calvin Candie
was so uncomfortable the amount of times
you got to say the word that his
co-stars Jamie Foxx and samuel l.jackson
had to intervene
the film's violence was also troubling
to many audiences in particular a scene
in which a slave is eaten alive by dogs
for some reason however there wasn't
much controversy about Tarantino's
ridiculous decision to cast himself as
an Aussie despite the nonstop violence
and profanity portrayed on screen Django
Unchained was a major hit earning 162
million dollar stateside and a
staggering 425 million dollars worldwide
on a 100 million dollar budget Django
Unchained was also a hit scum award
season earning 5 Oscar nominations and
two wins for Crystal fault says
supporting performance and Quentin
Tarantino's original screenplay
there had been rumblings around the
possibility of a joker centric film for
some number of years before 2019 with
Hollywood heavyweights Martin Scorsese
and Leonardo DiCaprio both groomer two
have been attached at some points when a
film was finally announced it would be
with the hangovers todd phillips
directing and joaquin phoenix donning
the grease paints the reaction from fans
was mixed then Joker did the unthinkable
winning the coveted Golden Lion at the
prestigious Venice Film Festival this
put joker a comic-book movie in the same
company as some of the most critically
acclaimed and artistically respected
films of all time it was an achievement
no other comic book movie or any other
commercial blockbuster for that matter
had ever accomplished the talk was that
Joker wasn't just a good movie it was
that Joker actually transcended his
genre into the realm of high cinematic
arts and almost immediately the
controversy began around the same time
the film was receiving euphoric praise a
counter-narrative was brewing that
claimed Joker could potentially inspire
violent and stable loners into
committing violent acts Phoenix even
walked out of an interview when he was
asked if he thought the movie might
inspire violence despite winning one of
biggest prizes the critical response was
muted with only a 68% fresh rating on
Rotten Tomatoes
however moviegoers loved Joker
propelling it to a record-breaking 96
million dollars opening weekend nearly
double its 55 million dollar budget
giving Warner Brothers more than plenty
to smile about check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]